الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب اعلن
عن اطلاق مجموعه من بطاقات التداول رقميه
بنظام رموز غير قابله للاستبدال انا اف تي
البطاقات تصور ترامب ازياء واشكال مختلفه
فتره يظهر كبطل خارق وتارك رائد فضاء
عندما كان معارضوه يصفوه بالشخصيه
الكرتونيه استمع لهم وحول انتقاداتهم الى
مشروع انافتي ها هو اليوم يظهر على شكل
شخصيه البطل الخارق تعالوا لنا طلعوا على
اخر ظهور للرئيس ترامب منذ علينا ترشحه
للانتخابات الرئاسيه المقبله
[موسيقى]
البطل وبعينه
الغرب القديم وسلسله الشخصيات الخياليه
الاخرى
اكتبي بدايه الفيديو
على انه الرئيس المفضل في كل العصور
[موسيقى]
ايضا في سحب الجوائز التي تشمل عشاء خاصه
كوكتيل في منتجعه مررغو في العاده تكلف
بطاقات التداول الرقميه حوالي العشرين
دولارا التي كثيرا ما يطلب ترامب من مؤيده
المساهمه فيها ولكنه اليوم يطلب مقابل
99 دولارا رقميا فقط
يا صباح العربيه للتسليمان واشنطن